en marche martinique le parti
présidentiel son coordinateur est avec
nous ce matin dans son caddie bonjour
jacky le courtier bonjour monsieur viol
temps bonjour aux éditeurs de martinique
1ère emmanuel macron le président de la
république sera aux antilles la semaine
prochaine jeudi et vendredi il se rendra
notamment à sa pierre jacky le courtier
pourquoi la section martinique est en
marche est aussi silencieuse ce n'est
pas important la visite d'un président
issu de votre formation politique
c'est très très important est la
meilleure des preuves c'est que je suis
là donc nous ne sommes pas silencieux on
a dû vous sollicitez quand même on
aurait pu on aurait pu vous entendre un
peu plus à la proche de cet événement
écoutez je pense qu'il ya deux choses la
première c'est que effectivement on pas
par faire le pied de grue devant les
médias vous m'avez sollicité va vous
avez sollicité en marche plutôt plutôt
que moi vous avez sollicité en marche et
donc je suis là aujourd'hui ce matin
pour vous parler bien sûr du de la venue
du président de la république mais
surtout des mesures qui ont été prises
par israël là on y arrivera mais
n'empêche n'importe quel autre parti
s'en seraient donnés à coeur joie
d'avoir son favori venir sur son
territoire oui mais nous sommes fiers
mais nous ne sommes pas non plus
n'importe quel parti il vient voir les
martiniquais il ne vient pas on voir la
république en marche
vous êtes attendus au tournant jacky le
courtier vous en marche
le président de la république annonce
des plans qui ne satisfont personne le
plan pauvreté 8 milliards en quatre ans
ventilés sur la martinique se serait
qu'à rentrer millions seulement
une misère compte tenu de notre contexte
le plan santé en milieu de semaine et
professionnels du secteur ne savent pas
s'il faut en rire ou s'il faut en
pleurer là aussi on est loin du compte
monsieur viol ton il ya quelque chose
qui me choque dans vos propos c'est de
faire des calculs mathématiques le
calcul je relaye ceux qui sont dans les
secteurs non c'est notamment sur nos
antennes qu'ils ne font que des calculs
mathématiques
aujourd'hui le président de la
république fait des annonces de
milliards et que vous dites
8 milliards 4 milliards se fit 12
milliards donc c'est quand même quelque
chose d'important et on ne divise pas sa
part le nombre d'habitants en dix ans le
la corrèze aura tant la martinique aura
temps et c'est pas comme ça que ça se
passe
nous avons aujourd'hui il faudrait que
ça se passe comme ça quand
se tenant compte surtout des contextes
exemple voilà là je suis d'accord avec
vous faudrait tenir compte des contextes
et nous allons tenir compte des
contextes
ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui la
martinique ayant un nombre de chômeurs
importants ayant un problème sur la
santé très important il est évident que
nous aurons plus dans dans ce dans ses
programmes qu un calcul mathématique
nous aurons plus effectivement que les
hauts-de-seine forcément
et je pense que aujourd'hui il faut
prendre le relais auprès de notre
ministre des outre-mer et nos élus
devraient prendre ce relais pour
justement c'est son rôle faire en sorte
que la martinique
je voudrais pas parler de spécificités
parce qu'il y en a un petit peu marre de
parler des spécificités de la machine
est efficiente et existe mais il faut à
ce que le chômage à 9 1% c'est
exactement mais ça ne s'est pas des
spécificités ses des constatations et
c'est pas des spécificités parce que
spécificité c'est péjoratif
déjà qu'ils accourent trier vous aviez
dit en novembre 2016 lorsque en marche
martinique voyait sa création s'est dit
qu'en marche martinique serait un autre
canal pour faire remonter les
informations du terrain auprès des
instances dirigeantes s'est fait ou
s'est pas fait alors non seulement c'est
fait je vous avais dit deux choses je
vous ai dit que nous étions là pour
écouter la population ce que nous avons
fait à travers la marche des mornes et
que nous étions là aussi pour faire
remonter les instances usap largement
oui bien sûr nous avons eu un stand by
pendant les congés et la marche demande
va reprendre s'amplifier ce que je
souhaite qu'elle s'amplifie de manière à
faire le tour des communes le plus
rapidement possible et là vous
expliquerai le plan pauvreté le plan
santé vous dirait par exemple vous
entendrez par exemple ce que disent des
martiniquais sur la baisse des dotations
sur des contrats aidés des organismes
c'est le tissu associatif
je je je suis pas là pour si vous voulez
dire on a la science infuse et on va
tout expliqué en justifiant tous moi je
pense qu'il ya des mesures qui ont été
prises et qui sont des mesures des très
bonnes mesures alors le problème c'est
qu'on a toujours tendance à dire ce qui
ne va pas mais on oublie de dire ce qui
va bien et quand même dans les mesures
qui ont été prises quand aujourd'hui
vous avez par exemple pour les lunettes
et pour elodie ti vous avez un rêve
0-1 reste à 0 pour les la population
c'est pas rien c'est un pouvoir d'achat
en plus mais ça ça passe en dessous de
bienvenue car elle de voir ce qui ne va
pas d'abord oui mais qui devra les
glaciations vous disent qu'on a plus les
moyens d'amener des actions pour
accueillir la jeunesse martinique et
celles qui étaient en train de se
construire
parce qu'on ne peut plus avoir recours
aux contrats aidés qui déjà sont une une
ineptie en soit on va bien le comble le
comprendre mais quand même ces
associations besoin de ces contrats
aidés et aujourd'hui des associations
ferme la porte tout simplement parce
qu'elles n'ont plus les moyens de faire
face alors les associations moi je suis
tout à fait d'accord avec vous je pense
qu'il y a un travail à faire encore même
s'il a été fait est que par rapport à
l'hexagone la martinique qui a pas été
le plus mal loti mais il ya encore un
travail à faire parce que je pense si
une priorité à donner c'est vraiment
pour les associations qui sont un tampon
social au niveau de la martinique et là
je serai vraiment celui qui va défendre
très fort ce domaine là parce que là
vous avez raison il y à vraiment à faire
remonter le mécontentement parce qu'il
est justifié car ferez vous pour faire
passer le message du président qui n'est
pas que le président des riches comme on
entend assez souvent et que ces actions
sont selon lui une chance qu'il donne
aux générations futures et qu'il n'est
pas question de détricotage social
comment vous allez vous y prendre ici en
martinique comme partout je pense que il
faut aujourd'hui faire un constat c'est
que le président de la république quand
il a été élu a dit qu'il voulait la
transformation du pays
vous savez on est dans un pays qui est
une maladie chronique
on ne soigne pas une maladie chronique
comment soigner un rhume il faut du
temps
ça fait 16 mois qu'il est là donc je
pense qu'il faut quand même attendre un
petit peu les résultats les mesures qui
viennent d'être prises on commence à les
juger
avant même qu'elle soit appliquée donc
un petit peu de temps un petit peu de
patience même si je comprends
l'impatience des habitants des
martiniquais je le comprends parce qu on
a fait tellement de promesses en
politique qui n'ont jamais été tenues
donc je comprends parfaitement leur
alors comment fonctionne en marche
martinique vous avez une référente
charlotte crise si vous à votre
ordinateur si vous même vous avez un
comité politique avec 3 mais rate mon
plaisir justin pamphile écrit sur
affaires ainsi que comité de pilotage
tout ce qu'il faut pour que la vague en
marche
swala soit bien visible sauf qu'on ne la
voit pas mais si on la voit pas ce que
vous n'êtes pas vous n'êtes pas dans les
villes dans lequel on va au moment où on
y va mais on la voit mais on aimerait
reprendre
on aimerait entendre justin pamphile on
aimerait entendre râle font plaisir
christian raf également même s'il n'est
pas officiellement marche
je pense que si vous les invités vont
pas refuser vos invitations il n'y a pas
de problème
nous on a des contacts réguliers avec
eux et je pense que si vous tuez comment
ça se passe vous réunissez vous discret
vous discutez de d'une action politique
de méthodes opératoires
si vous voulez je pense que la
réunionite qu'il faut aussi faire très
attention
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans une logique
nous sommes un jeune mouvement
nous sommes dans une logique
d'implantation et comme on vous l'avait
dit dès le démarrage si on n'a pas
d'implantation on n'existe pas donc le
but aujourd'hui n'est pas de faire de la
réunionite pour se faire plaisir
il est aussi d'aller sur le terrain et
faire de l'implantation
ça c'est notre premier travail et
ensuite
mais selon randall et s'apprend et ça
prend très bien monsieur viol tombe mais
je sais aussi qu'on le dit ce matin va
écouter vous n'avez personne pour me
contredire mais bien sûr si je vous le
dis mais moi je vois marcheurs à peu
près 700 marcheurs si moi je le vois si
vous voulez quand on fait ses marges
les gens on est bien accueilli les
journaux s'attardent sur la petite tape
sur le dos là non c'est sa petite tape
sur le dos il ya des gens qui nous
disent leur mécontentement je ne le
cache pas ils nous disent le
mécontentement les retraités nous disent
président de la république exagère un
petit peu on explique jeu ils le disent
un petit peu abilities oui il y en a
j'en ai rencontré également des
retraités qui disent qu'il exagère un
gros plat non il vient de faire encore
un petit geste d'aujourd'hui
le gouvernement a annoncé un geste moi
je pense qu'il ya effectivement des
choses des mesures qui ont peut-être
peut-être était pas très bien expliqué
mais globalement quand même quand vous
prenez tous les plans toutes les mesures
qu'ils ont fui y ont été annoncé
ça fait 30 ans 40 ans qu'on n'a pas eu
autant de mesures
quand on dit qu'il faut éradiquer la
pauvreté en france c'est un nouveau mot
alors il faut que ça se soit concret je
suis d'accord avec vous mais c'est quand
même un nouveau langage c alors on a un
président qu est jeune c'est un nouveau
langage
ce sont des nouvelles méthodes il faut
aussi s'adapter à
nouvelle me donnait pas surpris parfois
par certaines de ses sorties lorsqu'il
rencontre cette population bah pas
surpris la msa ses comptes de la
jeunesse également une pas du tout c'est
un homme responsable
je pense que responsable qui sort ce we
non mais je pense qu'elles sont souvent
sortis de leur contexte et qu'on fait
beaucoup de buzz avec ses phrases
sorties de leur contexte je pense qu'il
ya aucune méchanceté dans dans ce qu'il
dit et il n'y a aucun mépris surtout
quand il le dit alors après on s'amuse à
faire du buzz sur internet
mais c'est pas très important vous savez
le casse-toi pauv' con et sfr c'est
certainement beaucoup plus grave jacky
le courtier on l'a dit la semaine
prochaine emmanuel macron se rendra à
saint pierre donc la ville de gruissan
rafa qui n'est pas membre officiel dans
marche sur la route il aurait pu
s'arrêter à case-pilote oui la vectra
délai qui lui est en marche
oui c'est ce que nous avions fait cette
proposition qui s'arrête à case-pilote
qu'ils puissent éventuellement aussi
aller au lorrain puisque nous avons deux
de deux maires qui se sont engagés là
vraiment fortement et ça nous aurait
fait vraiment plaisir
maintenant vous savez un voyage
présidentiel c'est très compliqué et
quand il est je dirais enclencher les
difficile de faire des vous invite à
consulter en temps qu'en marche
martinique sur son programme son
parcours ce qui devrait faire ou pas ati
personnel non à merci jacky le courtier
d'avoir été avec nous ce matin dans son
casier on rappelle que vous êtes le
coordinateur du mouvement en marche
martiniquais bonne journée merci
oh
[Musique]